[Music]
I'd like to welcome everybody to
tonight's just class on the Romantic
period of chess I have a couple of the
main representatives we're going to go
through games by Paul Morphy the first
American champion he won a beat a lot of
the European masters in 1858 the best
European player that he ran into was
Adolph Anderson from Germany who was 18
years older than Morphy Anderson was
actually a mathematics professor in
Germany that's what he played chess is a
hobby Paul Morphy was the chess prodigy
he learned to play by watching his
father and uncle play and he was trained
as a lawyer he went to Tulane University
in he was from New Orleans and he went
to a university down there in Louisiana
but later became Tulane they changed the
name anyway he graduated and he was 21
years old and he couldn't start his law
practice because he wasn't old enough so
he won the American chess tournament in
New York City the first one and then
they invited him to play the Masters in
Europe so he travelled to Europe to play
the best chess players in the world in
our first game here you can see is Paul
Morphy as white versus Adolph Anderson
and this was played actually was played
in France
Anderson traveled from Germany to Paris
Morphy traveled from New Orleans to
London and then to Paris so that's where
the game was played in December 28th 18
viii morphe was 21 years old and
anderson was let's see anderson was 40
40 years old
so anyway morphe always almost always
played efore in this anderson very
disowning is quite a bit he plays a
French defence but I must say he plays a
very bad French defense this is the on
move - he tries out a new idea fee and
shadowing the the bishop on g7 and the
standard move in the French defence if
you're familiar with it is this move
stablishing the strong center with the
two pawns and that's generally a good
for equality of both sides play properly
g6 on the other hand weakens the black
squares or see all the pawns are on
white squares and the black squares are
weakened for the rest of the game and he
doesn't establish a center pod but it's
not a losing move it gives white and
easy advantage you can see the symbol
left in the little square box says g6
which is the move question mark
bad move Plus over equals is the sign
for a slight advantage for white and in
parentheses I put what the computer
evaluation was which was a plus 0.6 for
for white and that's where one pawn
equals 1.00 so 0.6 for is a little more
than half upon almost two-thirds of a
punt I guess not enough to win
grandmasters need about one pawn or more
so the computer evaluations need to be
1.00 or higher for the grandmasters to
Wed but after two moves that's a nice
advantage for white anyway Paul Morphy
places Bishop up to d3 which is a pretty
good move
he Paul Morphy one of his trademarks was
very rapid development of the pieces he
he moved some Center pawns out and then
he does almost everything with his
pieces so he brings to the bishop up the
computer I use said that rather than the
bishop move he would have been even
better had he brought the knight out
first often it's better to bring the
Knights out because they take a couple
moves to get to the middle of the board
and the bishops can go further the
knight can only move three squares at a
time
now black would go ahead and fee and
shuttle his bishop according to the
computer analysis the other night should
come out black plays the D pawn up one
squares to cover the center squares and
then white can bring out his black
scored Bishop attacking the Queen and
this maintains White's advantage that he
got after black made this weak opening
move again it's not sufficient to win
but it's a nice advantage anyway Bishop
to d3 isn't a bad move it just doesn't
maintain as much of an advantage and it
lets black equalize later on so black
develops his bishop and Paul Morphy
brought out his other bishop and black
makes a pretty serious mistake right now
his best move was to go play the
standard French move even later he needs
to establish his pawn center it holds
back the white pawns that's why it's so
important to play d5 had he played this
you can see that the computer evaluation
is still a slight +4
Plus over equals but it's only a point
three three advantage which is a third
of a pawn and white often has a third of
a pawn just due to having the first move
so that's a normal sort of advantage but
black played c5 attacking the center
pawn on d4 which is a good idea but in
this case it it wouldn't work had white
responded with his best move you can see
that the evaluation is now + / - no
longer + / equals + / - is a big
advantage for white and you can see that
the point evaluation jumps up to 0.96
that's almost a one-point advantage
that's almost a winning advantage not
quite of the again the best move even
here was the d5 move and it would be
0.33 so what's wrong with c5 well the
problem is the c5 pawn is not protected
but black is counting on the fact that
his bishop on g7 right here if that pawn
moves he he can take this pawn and then
win the rook so he'd win a rook for a
bishop rooks worth five pawns Bishop
three black would be up to point
equivalent of two pawns but the flaw in
that idea is that white should take the
pawn and give up the rook and white gets
a very strong attack against blacks
position because black has weakened all
the black squares over on the King side
you can look at almost all blacks pawns
are in white square so he doesn't have
any pawns to cover black squares so Paul
Morphy did not want to give up his rook
so he played a
aníbal move c3 protecting the pawn now
the question mark exclamation mark after
that means that's the dubious move it's
not a bad move but he had better and you
can see the computer evaluation drops
down to just point three four after that
move here's what the computer said he
should do he should take the pawn black
takes that pawn bring out the knight so
the Queen protects the rook Bishop takes
Queen takes now white threatens Queen
takes rook it forces another pawn move
by black f6 to block the Queen and then
white brings up his knight see the
Knights headed for a black square
there's no bishop to defend it
the knight gets wedged in on d6 with a
check and blocks blacks pawns that gives
white the much better game much worth
much more than the exchange he gave up
the best move for black here is to move
his King over to the King side behind
the pawns the knight drops in with check
and the black King would go here I
didn't go any further the computer he
says this is now a huge advantage for
white plus over minus one point five for
one and a half pawns it's still not
according to the computer it's not
winning if it was winning for white it
would be a plus sign to the left and a
minus sign to the right see they put the
the white reference first the plus is on
the left and the minuses on the right
that would have been black now when one
is over the other like it is here + / -
the plus they put the white on top and
the black is on the minus so the plus
means it's a big plus for white and
minus means it's a big minus for black
and the computer gives you the point
about one point five four
again 1.0 is a one-point advantage this
is one and a half pawns that's usually
enough for a grandmaster to win so Paul
Morphy did not play the best move which
is unusual for him he didn't play a bad
move though he still has a small
advantage of a third of a pawn black
traits the center pawns and brings his
knight out more if he brings his knight
out black brings the other night out
both sides castle and white brings his
Knight out and finally black plays the
movie could have played on the second
move he establishes a setter pod it's a
good move here white place for the
attack white is not going to trade pawn
see how that pawn right here on e6
blocks this Bishop that's a bit that's a
tie positional advantage for a white
that Bishop being blocked by its own
pawns it would be a bad mistake for
white to do pawn takes pawn because then
this pawn takes and the bishop can has
an open diagonal to enter the chess game
so Morphy advances the pawns which is
the correct strategy it's the typical
French move to now Anderson does the
good move he immediately attacks the
center pawn with f6 and morphe
reinforces the center pawn with i-4 this
is all standard takes and then F takes
and white is better I see that white is
the only one with a pawn on the fifth
row his pawn on the fifth row is
protected by a pawn and that pawn on d4
is protected by the bishop and the
knight so black can never win that
Center pawn see how the two white pawns
block this bishop so this bishop has no
good moves they can't go here because
the white bishop is guard
the square now that black isn't lost his
bishop is very key to defend these black
squares and it defends the king I mean
it's it's right in front of the King so
it helps defend the King and black in
trade works with this open F file and he
can get enough space to move his pieces
around he's not lost but black has no
winning chances white has it when when
with White's pawn on the fifth row he
can move his pieces freely from side to
side and up the middle and black is
cramped you can see that this Bishop can
only go here and it's blocked by this
pawn it could maybe come out here and if
it goes back here it's blocked by this
pod so this Bishop is pretty pathetic
that's called a bad bishop when you have
a bishop blocked by your own pawns in
chess they called a bad Bishop because
the pawns limit future moves into the
white territory so black is is condemned
to passive defense now he can hold the
game but he has no winning chances
whatsoever okay
now black after pawn takes pawn the
computer says black is equal you see the
little equal sign and black immediately
makes a bad move that puts his game in
jeopardy and what does he do he plays a
six I told you that Paul Murphy's thing
was to rapid development so he gets his
pieces out the as his Center pawns and
then he moves his pieces to either
attack wherever he can he loved to
attack on the Kings side he's going to
build up a King side attack black
doesn't have time to waste moves with
pawn moves black needs to start
preparing his defenses on the Kings side
because White's gonna
his pieces over there and start a very
strong attack now blacks Bishop blocks
the rook on a eight and that rook needs
to the Queen the bishop needs to come
here and the Queen needs to come here so
the two routes protect each other and if
white does Rick takes work you don't
want to take with the Queen because this
workers eventually is going to move here
and attack the Queen it would be best if
you could take if he does Rick takes her
a check you would like to take with this
rook over here and then you would be
fighting for that control that open file
the F file so a6
that's why a6 is such a bad move it's a
waste of time it's unnecessary it does
nothing for black it does take away two
squares from white well one square this
the knight can't go here nor can the
bishop go there but White had no
intention of going there anyway
remember White's going to come over to
the King side not the Queen side so what
should black have done well what black
should have done right away he should
have traded rooks rook takes her a check
that's an excellent move because see
White's two rooks aren't protecting each
other he can't bring the rook on a1
because the Queen if whites Queen was up
here then the rook would come over and
he would have custody of that F file
with his rook well he takes with the
Queen but that Queen de can't control
the file because when the bishop moves
up and the Queen moves up that black
works gonna come over and attack the
Queen so that's what that's what black
should done instead of wasting the pawn
move then he should have brought his
bishop up C he should have moved his
pieces and not played with pawns this
that's a good Bishop move it comes up in
a tax
pins the knight to the Queen and attacks
this square which is weak it's only
defended by the bishop and the pawn
attacks it and the Queen attacks it
that's a great move but it doesn't win
then he should move his Queen out of the
wait now he's ready to bring this work
in the action from the Queen side and
drives the White Queen away White's best
move is to move the Queen up the Rick
comes over and then white would drop his
bishop into that weak Square words
protected by the pawn but black has a
good counter-attack now see how this
bishop here is undefended now white
wants to move this rook here black can
throw a spanner in the works by this
move attacking the undefended bishop now
he could defend the bishop with the rook
but then the knight would take the
bishop and that bishop is a good
attacking piece so the computer says
better than giving up it's better to
retreat the bishop but the drawback to
that is the bishop blocks the rook and
the work can't go where he wants to go
at least until he drives to the knight
back moves the bishop out so it cost him
one two three moves you see so that's
why that night to be forward was such a
good move anyway
black follows up by putting his Queen
see how the Queen attacks this pawn now
that part's defended by this by the
knight and by the Queen but one of those
pieces will have to stay and protect
that pawn black is getting a count
possible counter-attack and the black
Queen when white drives the knight back
with a three the knight will go to a six
and the Queen will be attacking the pawn
on b2 which is undefended so when you're
defending you are you try for a
counter-attack
best move is and then you don't go to c6
that would block the bishop you see the
bishop can come up this way and come in
this way and maybe take a knight and
reduce the attack and that solves your
bishop problem you're not blocked by
pawns it'd be a mistake to go back there
and block the bishop so you go here and
the computer says it's completely even
so in this position all black had to do
was rook takes rook and he with the
proper follow up instead he made a and
you'll hear this in classes all the time
don't waste chess moves when you make a
move in chess it's time it's a temple a
move by white is one temple moves our
move pairs white and black so move one
white moves black moves that's a move
pair temples and moves are half moves
the white move is a half move if you
waste your move and black wasted a move
that gives white an extra move or temple
and white with this move you be
interesting to see how white tears black
apart eventually so he moves the Queen
up now you can see the rooks or protect
each other and if black does rook takes
rook now the Queen isn't there but the
other work is there he missed his chance
and the knight comes up a move too late
the bishops protected by the Queen so he
doesn't retreat the bishop in this case
blocking the rook he moves his black
squared bishop up to that attacking
position we talked about attacking here
pinning the knight black does get rid of
the bishop however it doesn't solve his
problem see he still has a problem with
his
bishop now his Knights pin and he
doesn't own he doesn't fight White's
gonna do rook takes rook and then Queen
takes or Bishop takes the other Rick
comes over and White has the only work
on the F file attacking eight seven
squares in front of it okay so but black
finally gets his Bishop up he should
that would have been a better move than
eighty six also white see how white
shifts the Queen over to the King side
attacking this and this that's going to
prevent this Bishop for moving anywhere
because it would be Queen takes pawn
check he brings his Queen over now white
brings us now see how the knight came
from e2 up here and see blue one of the
that the reason he moved his Queen was
so he unpinned the knight he's going to
move the knight that this is a good
square for the knight it's protected by
two pawns and it blocks the white so
Morphy who's white hurries up to bring
his knight to g3 where it can take the
black knight when the Black Knight gets
to a good square and one of the pawns
I'll take and that wipe that Bishop is
still blocked by his own pawns so he
brings the other work over to c8
white takes Queen takes see how white
gets the attack on the Queen Queen back
now he brings his queen up that
reinforces the bishop and the Queen see
he can't drive the bishop away with this
bond he loses a pawn and white threatens
Bishop takes Knight driving and trying
to drive the night the night
a good defender of where it is black
falls for moving the night up you wanted
to go to f5 he thinks it's a good move
but it's not he comes up here and you
can see that's a bad move and now white
gets a big advantage once again plus
over - and the computer says it's one
point one one one and one tenth pawn
advantage that's enough for most modern
grandmasters to win the game ok what
should buddy what would have been better
it's better but it's not it doesn't save
the game it would have been better to
retreat the bishop and defend the knight
then move the knight but retreating the
bishop to f8 is lousy - because look it
leaves the f6 square wide open so I'm
not saying it's it's it's just a better
defense White has a point four five
advantage about half a pawn after Knight
to f5 it's one point one in a tenth
advantage so white takes the night that
was black's best piece so you want to
trade it off and the other thing is this
white knight can't go anywhere see how
it's blocked by the pawns so the only
point for the night was to trade it so
he trades it G takes now you see this
the King is there's no pawn in front of
the King on the G file White's going to
come up like this this is called a rook
lift you put the rook to the third row
and you bring it in front of your pod
that's a very strong attacking maneuver
so he's going to do that at some point
well right away
now black makes the losing blender a bad
blender which loses quickly but he's
lost anyway but this this will wrap it
up now look what happened to the point
evaluation it jumps to three point five
nine three point three and a half Pont
advantage three pawns
that's a knight or bishop advantage and
he has the half pawn on top of that so
black is dead lost and more if he knows
just how to finish him off
he brings his Rick over aiming at the
bishop and King and the threat is Bishop
to f6 and the rook Bishop will threaten
rook takes Bishop check and look the
Queen can go up to h6 so we're going to
have Bishop here Queen here and rook
here all on that poor Bishop black
brings up his see this he finally got
this Bishop out to a a square but it
does nothing that through eight it can't
defend it can't come back to the King
sight see even if it can't even if four
it can't come down here the rook would
take it but even if he could take it
this pawns in the way he can't defend so
that he got his Bishop to a worthless
square and now White's going is
finishing him off so the bishop comes up
now anderson can't move his pieces very
much so he is desperate he gives up a
pawn now why does he do that he's hoping
that at some point he can drop the
bishop here and then block the rook and
the bishop would be protected by the
pawn but that's not going to happen
anyway loses the pawn then he reinforces
his bishop with the queen but it's
bishop still pinned to the king
and now white takes that lousy bishop
and black has double pawns on the
queenside that cannot be defended and
white can trade off all the pieces on
the kingside marches King to b4 and take
the b5 pawn and take the Queen side
pawns then he can take that pass pawn on
a2 and make a queen out of it he doesn't
have to checkmate him so he brings his
queen up so he's got three pieces
attacking the bishop and Black has three
pieces defending the bishop which is
sufficient but because of his bat
don't forget but White has an extra pawn
on the King side that would be enough to
win blacks position on the Queen side
would be defensible if this pawn was
here see the two pawns would block the
white pawns and the back pawn would
protect the pawn here but here there's
no pawns that can protect it so black is
totally lost he moves his King over and
now white liquidates all the pieces he
brings up this pawn here at good ending
technique the King can only come up this
way see so what he does he brings to the
pawn up here taking away in this Square
from the King in this Square and it
takes this Square from the pawn he plays
his pawn up he doesn't really have any
moves now white brings these pawns up
see they make a wall the King can I go
past the pawns and if this pawn comes up
here the easiest is just to go the
easiest if this were to come here you
could take it and win but even you just
go here and the King can come
here here but it can never go up and
attack the plot because this past pawn
would walk in and Queen alright so after
h4 black can't do anything on this side
White's gonna he brings his other pawn
up now White's gonna waltz over boom
boom boom boom boom and boom and if the
black King hurries over to block these
two pawns come up and there's a passed
pawn on the King site the King can't
stop a pawn on the King side and the
Queen side at the same time that's hard
to do so he moves here one last-gasp he
just walks past it the white King will
soon win blacks Queen side pawns and
that's that okay now our second game the
interesting thing about and Murphy
went back to New Orleans
and tried to become a lawyer but he was
not able to break into the profession
for some reason and he got depressed
over that and he got angry he blamed
chess he he actually started up with
another lawyer they tried to start up a
practice and people morphe was famous
for winning all these chess matches he
was written up in the newspapers and all
this and people would come into his
office in New Orleans and all the men
would want to talk about his glorious
chess games in Europe he couldn't get
any legal clients he was unsuccessful he
got depressed over it his family was
wealthy they call it melancholy back
then they call it depression now and
they have anti depression medicines they
didn't have anything back then
he wasted the rest of his life he stayed
at the family home they were wealthy his
dad was a judge and he just kind of
walked around the city and didn't do
much of anything and eventually it died
fairly young about 48 or something and
because he blamed chess he quit he
announced to the world he had given up
chess and some famous chess players went
and visited him in New Orleans and he
even refused to play him welcome
Steinitz came all the way from Vienna
Austria he toured the America it wasn't
just to see morphe but he came down to
New Orleans talked to morphe but he more
if he wouldn't even play a man off and
game so that's that said as a result
Anderson was the best German player
Anderson did not have he was a professor
of mathematics professor he did not have
any mental issues they said in Wikipedia
he went on with us continued on with
many tournament victories in London and
France and Germany and after Morphy quit
playing chess the world once again
recognized that Anderson was the best
chess master then actively playing and
Anderson went on and he won many
tournaments he played till he was an old
man in fact he was playing in a
tournament when he got his final illness
and died later that year so this game
with Murphy I mean just called up was in
1858 Anderson had his best victory at a
famous tournament called baden-baden
that was a resort area in Germany in
1870 so 58 12 years later Anderson had
his best result and Anderson was born in
1818 so 20 from 1750 he was 52
years old when he won this tournament
anyway he's playing the British champion
Joseph Henry Blackburn July 29th 1870
we're gonna have to speed through it and
guess what Blackburn we see another
French Blackburn plays it properly
though now Anderson this is called the
winner where variation it's named after
another guy who was very famous chess
player back with in this day and age and
you know the bishop move Isle eights the
chess prints the opening principle that
you usually move your bishops beat your
Knights before your bishops so the older
the and it's still played today it's
called the the classical variation is
this the knight comes out anyway when a
were was it far advanced for his time
and he invented this and this is very
popular today it's considered the most
complicated variation in the French
defense it hardly ever ends in a draw
one side usually wipes out the other
side but both sides win so theoretically
it's considered good for equality
anyway the right move for white here is
to block the pawns for the same reason
you try to block in the white square
Bishop on c8 but again the opening
theory was not so developed back then
and Anderson just develops a piece and
protects his Center pawn and win a work
counter attacks with attacking the
center pawns white does pawn takes now
according to the computer a black ax get
complete equality right away if he just
equally takes pawn the Knights pinned to
the King and then black doesn't get a
weak isolated center pawn but this but
this is playable it's just not the the
easiest way to get equality
and here white miss plays it he had a
chance to get a decent advantage he
should do pawn takes pawn now you might
think that that might lose the knight
that's not the case because we can drive
the bishop away with this move and if he
takes the knight we take with the pawn
he can take our pawn then we have the
two bishops and he he has a hard time
defending his black scorch this is black
scored bishops gone and we have two good
bishops aiming toward the Kings side
this would be a big advantage for white
so white should have done D take c5 and
this is actually a mistake so the
computer says what black should do is
develop he brings the knight in front of
the King C White's going to come here or
here and castle and then the rook will
be here aiming at the King so what black
does he puts it here it protects the
pawn and there what the rook will be
blocked by the knight
all right then white brings his Night
Out and egos here to protect the knight
so that if Bishop ever takes he doesn't
get double pause he just takes back with
the knight castles castles night out
bishop up pinning the knight pawn up
forcing the bishop back Knight takes
pawn now Bishop takes Knight Bishop
takes Knight to f4 you notice that
there's a weak pawn there on d5
White's threatening Knight takes pawn
Knight takes Knight Knight takes Knight
Queen takes Knight there's a little
Bishop takes pawn check winning the
Queen black can't defend the pawn he
loses a pawn his best move is to block
the bishop now he takes the knight now
you don't do Knight takes because we
don't have a
shucks but you do the bishop move
pinning the knight to the king he can't
protect the night with his bishop
because our knight guards the e6 square
so we win the night back he moves the
King out of the way and we're a nice
pawn up its 0.67 advantage for a white
that's what that's what white should
have done instead he did Bishop up check
Knight comes out night out night out
castles and here black wastes time
remember I told you pawn moves or waste
of time well black just does it he has
complete equality all he had to do was
castle that would break then his Knights
not pin white can take the knight so he
should have castle taking the knight is
no big deal by white you just take back
with the pawn so you don't need to
hassle that Bishop the white bishop on
b5 for some reason black attacked it
with the pawn see black wasted a move
with a pawn move he could have castled
and had complete equality well so white
takes it and when you take you don't
lose time because the opponent has to
take back with a pawn
so temple wise that's us that's a match
and whites now get got got an extra move
fortunately for black white makes the
wrong move here
I told you that the white knight on e 2
protects the knight so if the bishop
takes the knight takes back well that
kind of toast now in this case white
should have made a pawn move because
there's a point to it it attacks the
bishop the bishop C is protecting the
pawn if he retreats we went upon so he
has to take the knight and the
grandmasters think bishops are a little
better than the knight so this improves
our position some slightly we take with
the night when you have good pawns and
according to the computer it goes like
this
check bishop blocks Bishop castles White
has a slight advantage of 2/3 of upon
point six six anyway
he moved his Knight over and threatens
pawn takes pawn but he missed the right
move which was just pawn to Queen ERK
three now black I see black advances his
his pawns and now his pawns are pretty
strong and they cramp white white
attacks the one pawn black takes it pawn
takes and black castles see so black got
castle making up for the lost movie head
from a six and now white makes said
further well he makes an inaccuracy he
goes over here with his bishop now he
needs to get rid of this bishop but he
should have come here to trade the
bishop and actually according to the
computer black shouldn't take and this
is an interesting point black could take
the bishop and you hear that you can
defend by a trading pieces but the other
thing is you don't want to trade pieces
if it helps your opponent develop so if
black
corta take see the queen takes back and
the white queen just got improved when
it was here it couldn't go on the white
diagonals it's blocked by night and pawn
okay and and here it's blocked by the
bishop so the right move for black is
Bishop back here yeah it Bishop back
here see now the White Queen is blocked
by the bishop Knight and pawn and white
would then go here to trade but the
difference is black doesn't do Bishop
takes that would bring the knight from
the second to the fourth row he just
leaves it there if white does then he
gets his queen from his first row to the
third row he develops another piece he
brings his rook which was behind upon
now he's attacking the knight he
improved his position so you don't just
trade pieces willy-nilly and you don't
trade pieces if it helps your opponent
sometimes you just retreat to a better
Square that's that's what he should have
done anyway so white should have gone
here but he went here and here's why
that's bad black takes it now that rook
is blocked by a knight and pawn and the
work is undefended that work doesn't
belong there he's going to have to spend
time most likely to move the rook back
here to come over this way so that costs
white a move when he put the bishop
there black traded and now it's gonna
cost him a move to move the rook to a
better squirt he attacks it immediately
that's good enough but I got to tell you
the computer says even better would be
to bring another piece out you see Rhett
you you really need to develop your
bishops and rooks before your Queen the
Queen can go anywhere and she can
develop at any time
I would have been better not to attack
the Rick right away but leave it there
as the future move and get the rook out
attacking the knight that's what he
should have done the knight would go
over here now the knight wants to go
here and here right well we move our
pawn up and we block those squares and
we give our King an escape square for
later on in the game and this would get
it they're both equal but this is closer
to complete equality than Queen the d6
okay anyway Queen here protecting rook
here Knight comes here rook up that's a
good move he's getting the rook from
behind a pawn it's going to come here
where it can come down this way so
that's an excellent move the knight
comes up see what a nice square that is
for the knight is protected by the pawn
and this is a backward pawn and it
attacks this pawn so the work has to
stay here to protect the pawn or he
loses the the knight and worker on the
pond well he makes a minor mistake here
what he should have done here when
there's a knight on G 3 you can attack
the knight with h 5 threatening here and
the knight has to retreat this is a good
attacking move for black C the night on
G 3 really isn't that hot it's it's a
way station the night wants to come up
here where it attacks the Queen now the
bishop would take it but White had nice
Eva's Queen here so it protects the
night and then he would take with the
Queen so if you attack the knight right
away with H he he still wants to get the
knight to the only move he has to bring
the Queen up it prevents this attack and
it threatens to win the pawn so black
has to move the pawn
but that's okay then he does the pawn up
that's a good move it protects the
knight more importantly it opens up the
rook which can swing over this way and
attack the King side so that's a great
move but black has resource he just
retreats the night driving the bishop
away the Queen goes in the Queen comes
over to defend rook comes here and that
Rick comes there and it's completely
even we're going to trade off all the
rooks and the black Queen it helps with
the knight white can't get in it's
complete equality so that's his best
move he does an okay move now white
misses a strong move see he member I
told you this pawn is inadequately
defended there's a knight and rook on it
so he moved his rook over too soon
and black does it white doesn't see that
he has a nearly winning move will wrap
it up in just a minute but here's what
white should have done he and I could
see why he would miss it this is tricky
rook takes pawn who would think you
could give up a ruck you only get a pawn
and you get a bishop but that's Bishop
and pawn is 4 vs. 5 but here's what
happens
Bishop takes oh look now the knight hops
in attacking Queen and rook the bishop
was keeping the knight out of their
queen back check rook takes oh we get
the piece back we got the rook back and
we're a pawn up and we're almost
point-seven advantage so white missed a
good chance and not only that this is a
weakening move once again black should
hit the night with h5 queen up now we
don't do g6 we hit the Queen why can't
the Queen take this pawn I wonder well
the reason is this Queen could come in
on this black square and hit this pawn
see the roots are coming down white
would be in maybe lose the game so he
has to stay keep he has to keep the
black Queen from going here alright so
night h7 he has to go to h4 he can't
take the pawn the Queen has to guard
this square and it turns out this is a
little better for black - the - in front
of the number means it's better for
black point to about 1/4 of a pot
alright so work - III see how the two
rooks were protecting each other and the
Queen is on the rook so the knight
interrupts the rooks and we win the the
rook for the knight the pawn can take
the knight the Queen can take the rook
this is only good for equality though
but black takes the knight that's the
wrong way what he should have done
according to the computer take with the
rook see he wins the whole pawn for
compensation and that pawn is protected
by Knight rook and the Queen is on this
pot and the computer says it's
completely equal with sufficient
compensation for the exchange so anyway
here queen takes
pawn takes Queen takes we Queen takes
pawn check Queen back Queen here be for
protecting the knight and letting the
Rick come over the knight comes up on
the Queen see for not the best move but
good enough Queen takes Queen here pawn
up h3 and now black blunders he has a
bit worst game head he should have
retreated the night he didn't want to
retreat the night he thought he could
get a strong attack attacking the Queen
but it's a blunder because we have a
check and we pick up the night he comes
here and threatens checkmate but we can
defend with rook up rook here King up
work on the Queen but we blocked the
rook with our work so White's completely
won here he's a whole piece up and
blacks king position is shaky and the
rook the Queen and IVA are ready to
attack the black King see the rook here
is threatening to win this pawn the game
is almost over we'll run through it
quickly Queen takes there watch this
this is pretty look we have two rooks
and the Queen attacking the King see
there are no pieces around the King are
there and there Noth there is the only
check is here but our Queen covers that
now he does threaten Queen takes Knight
but too little too late rook takes pawn
check breaks down the pawn barrier Queen
up King back Queen King over Queen here
pawns are falling like flies
Queenie err King here and there's
checkmate but black being a grandmaster
when he saw that move he resigned
it was mating form oops well thanks for
coming tonight that'll cover it this is
the Romantic period the old-time chess
masters they were quite good
grandmasters are better now that they've
learned a lot since 1870 but these guys
were very good and don't forget they
didn't have computers to tell them all
this stuff it's all done up here all
right
have a good night
you